[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the
ring over the last week or so I've
burned through the original Japanese
Trilogy the non-canon sequel spiral and
the American remake obsessing over the
tape if I'm dead in 7 days and you know
what happened but like the characters in
the movie it was difficult to stop
myself I think the Rings one of the most
unforgettable horrors of all time and
that final scene is forever burned into
my memory now I was actually someone
that saw the Remake before the original
and I didn't get around to watching that
until years later however it opened up
the well and made me become fascinated
with the genre with the original trilogy
becoming one of my favorites of all time
throughout this video we'll be doing a
deep dive on both ringu and its American
counterpart to talk about all the creepy
details that are laid in the films this
will also talk about the ending and
where they differ putting together the
major differences and things that they
changed if you enjoyed the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every week if you don't then
in the next seven days you'll you'll not
see the next one so yeah please do that
mate and thanks for the
support now ringu was a movie that
massively changed Cinema and it
subverted things away from the slashers
that had been dominant for decades its
reaches since been felt far and wide
with it influencing several forms of
media since its creation whether it's
stuff like the cursing it follows the
fear games or even The Grudge movies a
ghost girl with long black hair is now a
staple in horror it paved the way for
America remaking Japanese Horrors for
years to follow and basically open the
door for a whole new subset of films
based on the 1991 novel ring it saw
report of trying to get to the bottom of
a curs video tape that once watched
would kill you in 7 days now the book
actually took a little bit of
inspiration from Poltergeist with its
author recounting how the idea of a
ghost coming from a TV was something had
always stuck with him his name was Koji
Suzuki and he also went on to make
another classic in Dark Water which too
had a film adaptation and an American
remake now Sadako psychic abilities
they're actually based on a form of
spirit photography which in Japan is
known as nche this allows want to burn
images from their mind onto a solid
surface which in the movie is how the
character creates the video tape she
also takes inspiration from the Japanese
legend of the yokio which apparently
originates from hesi Castle according to
the Legends there was a servant girl who
was tortured and dangled over the well
at the castle before being dunked into
it where she was left in the days
following her screams could be heard
coming from the well and after she died
her spirit rose from it in order to
exact Revenge the title itself is
different interpretations as well with a
possibly having multiple meanings lays
throughout both films rings are of
course cires that move in a cycle and
the tape itself acts like a virus being
spread to whoever watches it upon seeing
the tape your phone also rings and the
view from the well Sako was trapped in
appears like a ring too Rings also
appear throughout both versions which
we'll be pointing out as we get further
into the video now this idea of Cycles
was continued in the now nonc canonized
sequel which was called spiral this
actually comes on The Ring 2 Blu-ray
released by arrow and it actually had a
bit of a weird release spiral came out
in the same year as ringu did so you
could literally finish the film and then
go and see its sequel it has them
actually examining how SOS curses like a
virus and it creates a new one that you
get by reading journals studying the
tape the ring then spirals out of
control and we end with several of the
characters resurrected talking about how
it's going to evolve Humanity honestly I
can see why it was dropped from the
Cannon as ring to's by far the superior
sequel that feels more in the same vein
as that tone in the original also we've
actually just just teamed up with Aro
films as a partner and if you're into
these older films then definitely go
check out I'll link in the description
you'll get 10% off any purchase and like
I said they've got the ring collection
RoboCop 4K The Exorcist and a ton of
older films recan and upgraded to 4K
again the link is in the description and
it massively helps out the channel click
it below or use the code heavy spoilers
at the checkout for 10% off now it's
hard to imagine how much of a success
this film was at the time but to give
you an idea it was the highest grossing
horror film in Japanese history now
obviously Hollywood being Hollywood they
wanted a piece of this too which in the
end turned out to be a pretty smart
decision the movie made $249 million off
a $48 million budget and in just the us
alone it did Bonkers numbers on DVD it
sold 2 million in the first 24 hours of
its release and it was a phenomenon that
built off the back of more Supernatural
Loki films like The Blair Witch Project
now for the next part of the video I'll
be going through the ring scene by scene
and talking about all the extra details
in it that you might not have picked up
amongst this I'll also talk about ringu
and some of the bits that differ or the
details in it that didn't make it to the
US version the films basically have the
exact same plot with a couple of
character changes but I think the best
way to tackle both movies is just in one
breakdown if you're looking for what one
you should watch then I think ringu is
the better film and that's due to its
atmosphere characters and general tone
of it on the other side of this though
the US version has way better effects
and even comparing the two final scenes
side by side you can see where the extra
money comes into play due to them
remaking the movie it also gave them a
lot more hindsight and because of this
they were able to add a lot more
subliminal images and foreshadowing
throughout like I said this Rings lace
throughout and that comes from the off
with the DreamWorks logo if you look
very clo not that closely but if you
look closely you will see the ring
flicker on screen when we hit the D from
here we cut to an establishing shot of a
house and the first thing you're
probably going to notice is the green
filter of the top of it this is
throughout the entire film and I totally
forgot this movie is greener than a
matrix film this is obviously a choice
you know they didn't do by accident and
the creative team put it in play so that
the movie had an unnatural feeling to it
kind of makes you feel sick a bit and
according to IMDb trivia they all select
the entire thing so that characters
don't actually have a shadow gives a
feeling that something's not quite right
which we get immediately from the off
the opening shuttle also begins with a
heavy focus on a withered tree which
itself becomes an icon lace throughout
the film the tree is known as a Japanese
maple and the fruit that grows from it
is called a Samara Samara Morgan is the
name of the girl in the US adaptation
with the Japanese one being called
Sadako I will probably jump back and
forth between the names so bear that in
mind and Rachel's character is called
raicho in the original Rachel's ex is
called Noah whereas in ringu he's called
ruji and there son a in is K yachi
butchered the pronunciation on those but
the first line in the remake is pretty
witty I hate
television gives me headaches now this
opening is very similar to how the
original began with us getting two
school girls talking about the tape this
is very reminiscent of the opening of
screen which again is kind of building
off the back of the slasher genre but
going somewhere new here they're wearing
Japanese uniforms and this was done on
purpose as a tribute to ringu in that we
learn what actually caused the tape to
be created and he of a cabin in IU where
a boy tried to tape a sports game
selecting the wrong Channel he left the
VCR running and when you watched the
tape it had the strange images on it
this is what then started off the curse
and we learned sako's well was located
right underneath the cabin yeah they
kind of skip over the story and instead
go for some conspiracy theory stuff
about radio waves burning the molecules
in your brain you know I heard there's
so many magnetic waves traveling through
the air because of TV and telephones
they were losing like 10 times as many
brain cells as we're supposed
to like all the molecules in our heads
are all unstable all the companies know
about it but they're not doing anything
about it it's a big conspiracy the book
was originally written to be more of a
science fiction one with it later
becoming more in line with a horror the
sequel spiral leaned more in line with
that and the science here could be
something that explains how the
characters are killed the movie is often
thought to be a metaphor for
technophobia with screens in technology
being Twisted to take human life the
Japanese version framed a lot of the TVs
to be like shadowy screens watching the
protagonists and they're often plac in
the corners of rooms pointed directly at
the characters what you mean that's
that's the best way to watch TV now but
you'll understand it if you see it and
these shots give the television a sense
of intimidation now further ring imagery
appears on the clock which we cut to as
the phone starts to ring in both
versions it's aar's mothers calling them
which then leads into the TV starting up
KD ends up unplugging this in the US
version which then extends the scene and
takes it to upstairs we see a reflection
in the screen with Samara behind her and
then catch water dripping from under the
door as she goes upstairs all of this
wasn't present in the original with the
water of course linking in with samara's
death now in the room we get some really
subtle things that you'd only really
notice if you slow down the
footage let's play that again slow
down
so as you can see there's several images
from the tape that are difficult to pick
up with a naked eye this is something
that appears in both deaths caused by
Samara with it happening to Noah just
before he's killed too now just before
it happens we get a shot of the well
which they do something really cool with
throughout the film every time it pops
up in the movie Samar is a little closer
to the screen building to her eventually
crawling out it in the final act now
from here we cut to Aiden drawing a ring
which in the end is revealed to be a son
this is something that he constantly
draws throughout the film and we later
see as he has several drawings lined out
where it gets bigger and bigger
eventually this forms into a giant ring
like what Samara saw in the well showing
how this curse could have affected him
throughout the movie these subtle bits
of iconography also appear in this scene
beyond the drawings and we can see that
his teacher has little horses on her
shirt when Rachel walks along beside the
window we can also see a little board
with horses on it too and looking back
at Aiden's drawings he's created several
Rings now Rachel not really being there
for a son adds to the theme of
motherhood that keeps popping up you
have to remember that back in the '90s
and early u0s being a single mother
wasn't as accepted as it is today it was
certainly a Tabo subject you know lots
of kids had a difficult time with it and
though it is accepted more now it wasn't
as much back then now due to her job she
never really got to be a mother to Aiden
and thus he turned to his cousin Katie I
know that Aiden recently lost his cousin
yes and I'm doing what I can to find him
some good day care no that's not what I
meant by all means take your time I know
they were very close Rachel and Aiden
are really distant with a l just
referring to her by her first name in
the end she Embraces samara's corpse and
does this all to say these two lost
children which cementer as a mother
these two kids they haven't really had
one but in this Final Act she's seen as
saving them both now this separation is
also clearly pushing them apart and we
see some of the drawings that Aiden's
done of his cousin Katie these show her
body lying in the ground with her even
being underwater like what happens with
Samara later we see some of the psychic
photographs Samara did and there's one
especially that riffs on what the
drawings are like here we find out that
Aiden drew them the week before she died
and this could be because of two things
the first is that Katie told him about
the call and that she only had 7 days
left to live the second is it shows that
he has somewhat ESP abilities which sort
of links in with the original movie in
that both the kid and his dad II had the
powers with that also being what helped
caused the Divide between the two due to
his abilities he'd shut himself off from
his son whereas Noah just doesn't think
he's mature enough to be a father Aiden
very much had Katie as his only lifeline
and we even see in his room how he has a
picture above his bed signed by her
these scenes paint out the Divide
between the two with Rachel looking at
her son through the mirror to
symbolically show their separation in
the original after the intro he cut to
raiko interviewing students about the
tape before she came home to her son who
she'd left in the house by himself in
both the pair then attend the cousin's
wake with the Remake having Aiden
getting dressed on his own showing his
independence looking at the lampshade we
can also see black circular rings on it
and Rachel's top also has a girl dancing
in the middle of a black circle this is
clearly a ballet dancer however it could
also be a little nod to Samar being
stuck in the well now both versions the
son ends up going to their cousin's room
whilst the girl's mother discusses how
they found the body I love how this is
solely told to us in flashbacks and it
kind of builds Str through throughout
the film over what the attack looks like
the entire movie builds towards that
final scene with this getting hints
towards it lace throughout the films now
in both versions the sun sees his
cousin's legs running up the stairs but
this Apparition gets more Sinister
further into the movie how the Sun
watches the tape is Guided by one of two
things with ringu building off the back
of this haunting Vision in the original
it zos goes to apparently tells some to
watch it whereas in the remake he does
it off his own back personally I always
took Tomo as being s AKO whereas here
they're trying to sell us the idea that
she is one of the good guys with Aiden
we sees he catches something in the
reflection of the TV whereas in the
original the horror is more implied now
outside in both the protagonist
interviews some of the students and is
that is that Adam is that Adam that's
Adam broy that this scene appears in
both versions with the students talking
about how their classmates also died the
same time the cousin did Rachel
eventually goes and gets her son and we
see a ring- like mirror positioned above
her head just discovering a scrap album
we see all the people in it have their
faces scribbled out which is a new Motif
they made for the American Vision this
of course ties him with the distorted
faces in the photographs however it also
possibly foreshadows samara's long black
hair covering her face developing the
photos we see as they Chronicle a trip
and show when the group ended up having
their faces distorted Rachel then starts
to investigate the death and we see that
two died in a car accident this is a bit
of an odd to the original as we had a
scene where two of the students were
founded in their car all of them were
surrounded by screens and reflective
surfaces which is what Samara used as a
gateway to get out there was originally
going to be a scene where we also saw
one dying in a motorcycle accident where
Samara would have killed him by emerging
from his helmet visor traveling up to
the cabin we get a shot of rain running
down the window foreshadowing the water
that will later run down Noah's TV here
we see the sign for the shelter mountain
in which gets a slight update at the end
of the film around the hour 24 Mark
Rachel and knowah passed by it and we
can see that it says closed until
further notice this was because it it
turned out the manager watched the tape
and his death caused the place to get
shut down as she walks in the reception
we see a clock on the wall with two
rings of course being used as the faces
here she discovers a tape which is among
stuff like your Sherlock Holmes
Revisited Scent of a Woman all of which
will be getting breakdown soon and
garden pond just give me just give me
the tape that kills me please none of
those now there also CH on the top which
is about cannibalistic humanoid
underdwellers that rise from the sewers
to kill people there's also rage to kill
and these two last ones might have been
used as little Clues now in the middle
we have a tape slanted like how it is in
the original but in that it calls out a
REO as here it doesn't passing by the
red tree on the hill this becomes
prominent later on and the tape itself
has several things in it that pop up
throughout the film there's of course
the ring that becomes the well leid and
then the red blood in the water which
fores Shadows the horse's death next we
cut to a chair which looks like the one
Samara sat in when we see the interviews
that were carried out on her next says
black hair her mother's combing her in
the mirror which itself is circular to
play off the ring Motif we also have her
father standing in a window and a fly
moving across the screen that later
comes out of it this is to give the idea
Samara can climb out of it too with the
cliff also being what her mother jumps
off of now in the original they sort of
changed the character and in that she
was a psychic who predicted the eruption
of a volcano her name was shizuku yamura
and she was actually based on shizuku
mun this was a real person from the
early 20th century who used to give
psychic greeings to people in the 1900s
accused of being a liar this destroyed
her career and she took her own life
after the accusations next we see a
strand of hair coming out of her mouth
which Rachel herself pulls out later in
the film cut of the tree burning and
then a nail getting pressed into a nail
which we can't really show cuz YouTube's
turned into demonetizing everything
unless you're really big content creator
that doxes people who try and criticize
you well so off topic I heard if you
watch your sister Sniper Wolf video you
get a call that says 7 days and then she
shows up to your house and doxes you
through the ring camera anyway as we
learn in the well samar's fingernails
came off from trying to climb out of it
which this nail being removed obviously
ties back to there's also a horse's eye
and a ladder against a wall which Rachel
ends up later walking under this is
obviously a sign of bad luck and the
entire thing like an early a24 student
film we see horses also washed up on the
shore and lastly catch the well before
the static plays C to Rachel's eye which
then starts to dilate again creating
this ring effect with us getting the
soul focus on that also Rachel is called
Rachel Keller which I don't know I I
always thought that was a friend's
reference now the look in these scenes
is really striking with production
designer Tom Duffy looking at the work
of Andrew W to create the film's look
after getting the phone call Rachel
heads back home which is where we start
to get the countdown of the days in the
Japanese original they just used dates
but here we have this constant ticking
clock to tell us time's running out
Aiden ends up going to school and I love
how the bus ads got Fraser and Seinfeld
on it ah the early naughty St takes you
back now here he bumps into his father
which is played almost exactly the same
as how it is in the original there's
this real disconnect from the two with
ringu being linked in with his psychic
abilities Rachel is out of him because
he's an expert on video recordings
whereas in the original he was a
professor at a university and both he's
now dating a student with the American
version having them sort of rekindling
their relationship we actually see
Rachel wearing a Kirkland University top
at this point and discover that his new
girlfriend's going there too when she
comes in we can see a T-shirt has the
school on it showing how he picked up
both women from the same place dirty now
both have watching the tape while Rachel
goes outside and stands on the B balcony
we see a looking about and catch a woman
leaving a child inside the room
metaphorically showing the separation
between mothers and kids in another
apartment we see a ring-shaped thing on
TV before seeing a Japanese program
playing on another this is of course a
not of the original country of origin
and this is also followed up by a
reference to a different sort of
Thriller here we catch a man in a
wheelchair with a broken leg and also
some binoculars resting on the window
sill this is a little visual no to
Alfred Hitchcock's rear window window in
which James Stewart's character looks
into the windows of his neighbors on the
screen the man's watching race play out
and in rear window he broke his leg when
he was photographing one now in the
original rushi didn't actually get a
call at this point which was explained
further in the novel this was because
only those close to Samara got one which
is why the people in the cabin were the
only ones to get the message the
American remake plays it a bit
differently with her getting an answer
machine message that she ends up
deleting was probably telling her to
like the video and though Noah as
skeptical he then starts to believe it
at this point Rachel makes a copy of the
tape which is why in the end saves her
life I will talk about the true meaning
behind both endings later on but passing
on the curse is the only way to save
yourself now the Remake has a scene that
I actually think improves on the
original as we have Noah basically
explaining how videotapes and tracking
works it's a nice bit of info dump that
kind of talks about the science behind
it and how tracking can also be used to
unearth some hidden Clues we also see a
ring-shaped ob object behind Rachel and
I S I'll stop pointing them out just
except for that one outside where we see
the manhole cover looks like looks like
a R the be not the
beyy turning a Ryan AR now cut across to
the mental institution where we see
Katie's friend being escorted through
the coros they have a sheep blocking her
from the TV and this is actually another
of the Ring to in which the cousin's
friend was held up in an asylum like
what we have here here she was convinced
to leave her room due to a sheep being
put up and this would stop her from
seeing the TV here she passes by at okay
res in that things went wild with Samara
launching a psychic attack to her and
all the patients also Rachel yeah her
earrings are the earrings are like rings
and earrings has the word
ring now using professional equipment at
work Rachel's able to adjust the
tracking here she spots the mosco Island
Lighthouse which in real life is the
yina head one this was picked due to its
Eerie location and also because it's
supposed to be horned by a previous
Lighthouse Keeper looking it up online
we also see samara's mother who's
wearing black amongst the other
Islanders learning she hosts a horse
show we then get a brief Glimpse at
Brian Cox's character now again she
differs from the original as in that
sako's mother was in fact a psychic
performing a reading one day she was
accused to being a fraud and then Sako
psychically killed the journalist who
did it which caused attension to turn to
her realiz realizing how dangerous she
was her dad ended up killing her which
was expanded upon in the movie Ringo now
that paint sakoa in a Sy pathetic light
whereas the American version just shows
she's bad at the bone she was
deliberately wanting to hurt people
whereas ringu had much more of that
tragic backstory now samara's attacks
completely plagued the island with they
killing all the horses there due to them
annoying her in the photo we then see
her mother and his head which Rachel
circles with a black ring now we
discovered that this caused Anna to take
her own life which was also made worse
by hallucinations brought on by Samara
while looking this up Rachel scribbles
at her face and we see Noah's distorted
one on a monitor at a shop you're going
to die well spoiler love and his face in
the footage makes him realize the curse
could be real with Rachel we then get
the hair scene which shows the pressure
Samara is starting to put on her around
the room we get a strong focus on Water
2 with both a jugg and glass getting
attention given to them in the window
behind her we also see it rushing down
before it then starts to drip directly
out the telephone at this point we see
Samara in a chair which is when we get a
flash of her time being studied grabbing
Rachel's arm this leaves a burn which in
the original happened when we saw
visions of the backstory with her mother
waking up we catch Aiden watching the
tape with it ending showing Samara
getting further out the well now this
moment is a big deviation from the
original as in that this happened while
Reiko and yoi went out to a fathers in
the end he actually played a major part
because she left her son with him when
they went out to sodos after discovering
he had to make a copy she ended up
driving out to her dad's with a VCR
player and also a blank tape this
implied that she was going to ask her
father to watch it and this would end up
sparing his grandson we discovered in
the sequel that he indeed saw himself
and the theme of what you do for your
family was cemented in his sacrifice
this is a big change up from what
happens in the American version with
them origin having a new character that
we'll talk about later on now we see the
copy get thrown under the sofa with a
text saying that being similar to what's
in the American version Cut to day six
and we see Katie's notepad with drawings
on the chair horses in a ring Aiden's
left looking for his mother while the PE
head out looking for samar's Origins
Noah heads out looking for Anna whilst
Rachel heads out on the ferry which is
when we see the horse jumping over the
side the way samar's attack worked is
that it psychically scared them to the
point they didn't want to be on the
island and thus they ended up running
into the sea we get a shot where it runs
through the ferry and we hold on a car
window covered in raindrops highlighting
samara's control the name of the boat is
also the quinal which itself has at ties
to horses just after the boat turns we
also get the ring flash on screen for a
split second which can only really be
caught if you slow down the footage and
now heads out to the Asylum and we catch
a fly crawling on the door as he breaks
in he sees some electrical nodes hanging
out of a box one of which was tied of
the hair Rachel pulled out her mouth
these themselves look like rings with it
being a circle within a circle on the
island we then get a shut of the
lighthouse and the beach where the
horses drown before cutting to the ranch
standing under the window we then get
the same angle to where samara's Dad
stood out in the tape the bars in the
field they're completely empty with bran
Cox painting out an isolated man hiding
a dark secret weirdly he played William
Striker and X-Men 2 the air after whose
son Jason also put images people's heads
now in the expanded law we learned what
happened with her and samara's real
mother was held captive in a basement
where she was assaulted by a priest
Samara was born and then adopted by Anna
and her husband Richard but the trauma
of her early life manifested into her
powers spotting at his mirror this lets
her know this is the place but her dad
andies it ever being the case however
outside we also have a child's swing and
Rachel pulls out a drawing Aiden made
which lines up samara's face is further
screed scribbled up again foreshadowing
the hair being draped over it with Noah
we watch as he goes through the records
and sees some notes with Japanese
characters calling back to the source
material I always found these moments to
kind of be like the X Files where we
have characters actually investigating
paranormal things and trying to put
explanations to them in the thermop
photography we also see dinosaur
skeletons which may Link in with the
toys that Aiden has in his room I C to a
doctor's office and we get a further
focus on the time counting down with
right now just having one day left this
itself has a ring around the center with
circles also being on the doctor's
cardigan learning that everyone on the
island was affected by the Visions this
island somewhat kept the outside world
safe from her however she was taken to
the mainland at aola which is where she
was studied and experimented on learning
her dad Richard watched the tape of this
Noah heads out to try and stop Rachel
from getting close to him we see her
entering the home and can also catch a
Japanese canvas hanging up on the wall
appear hearing inside the mirror this
creates a ring around Rachel which
appears like it's closing in on her
Samara 2 is featured in this as well
with her standing closer to the camera
to Showcase what's to come Rachel
discovers a file and then sees a
centipede in it which crawls away like
how the one on the tape did we see that
Richard took the tape of his daughter
with a writing on that being the same as
the file Rachel plays this and then we
watch Samar in a room for hours with a
clock again look looking like you know
what it is now we discovered that she
never sleeps which is one of the final
things that Aiden and Richard says about
the character she never sleeps she never
sleeps we also see the therap
photography with a horse in a ring like
sun being imprinted onto one pressing
this onto carbon paper is how she put it
under the film with a videotape curse
being born from that the name Samara
also refers to the story of pointman and
Samara which is about a man who meets
death in a Marketplace before fleeing to
the town taking his own life Richard
does it using a bathtub which is similar
to the watery grave that Samara was
sentenced to they then discover that she
was kept in the barn with her room only
being accessible by a ladder this is of
course the one that appeared in the tape
and we see models of horses dotted about
it too horses are even in the wallpaper
which itself has their heads printed on
it finding the tree at shelter Mountain
burned into the wall this then takes
them all the way back to the cabin going
underneath it they then discover the
well which as we know was where some 's
body was in the original they actually
tried to empty the water out which led
to more tension as the sun started to go
down Reiko actually swap places due to
tiredness whereas here Rachel gets
knocked in by the TV now blinking you'll
miss a moment yeah blinking you'll miss
it we actually see Samar appear on it as
it slides down here she sees what
happened with her with it being Anna in
the remake who pushes her down the well
in the original it was of course her
father but they changed it here to have
Rachel saving her to be a sort of
reverse of it it this is all to do with
mothers of course and her body's then
exume with it seeming like this is what
breaks the curse finally this young girl
can rest but as we learn she wanted to
be out there and now the tape's being
spread Rachel learns to be closer to
Aiden sometimes
children yell or cry or draw pictures
and this brings things full circle from
the start when Rachel refused to look at
Aiden's Miss Keller I'm bothered by
these drawings
listen I I appreciate your concern but
my son lost his best friend three nights
ago he's just trying to deal with it
back at Katie's old house we see Noah
pick him up and finally the family are
ready to be together look they're
holding hands and stuff it's it's
wonderful and then uh Rachel showers and
we see water washing away which is meant
to give the idea that the curse is
broken too it's the perfect place to
fade out and give us a happy ending but
wait there's more realizing Aiden's Mark
hasn't faded it only did for Rachel
because her time had passed Cuttin Noah
using a magnifying glass which itself
looks like a black ring he also then
picks up his coffee cup which too leaves
a ring right on a newspaper now let's
pause the frame for a second and zoom in
on the guy's face and you might
recognize that as being Chris Cooper
this guy is a really famous actor who's
been in a number of different films and
that ranges from the born franchise to
American Beauty but why Paul why is this
guy's face used in a newspaper article
when he doesn't appear in the film well
that's because there were two big
deleted scenes involving the actor that
were cut from the film if we look at the
news report we can see how he kidnapped
a girl assaulted and then killed her
which had him locked up for several
decades in the film Rachel was going to
be investigating this because he said
he'd found God and was now getting
paroled what Rachel was going to do was
going to get Aiden to copy the tape and
then give it to his character so that
he'd take the kiss this was would be a
way in which they could kill someone bad
clear Aiden of the curse and use it as a
weapon on one of the worst people
imaginable these moments were cut
because they slowed down the pace and
instead we just get Chris's face in this
brief scene kind of agree to as I think
it's a way better ending to close out
what happens here with Samara climbing
out the TV to claim her next victim I
love how Rachel Rings him throughout and
that phone plays in the background which
itself was of course one of samar's
calling cards this scene yeah it's just
one of those ones that's going to stick
with you forever and I think it's one of
the most memorable in movie history just
the way the movie lures you into a false
sense of security and then pulls the rug
out it's an incredibly chilling scare
that I think's going to just stick with
you I Love The Way She Moves and kind of
glitches about the room dripping water
on the floor and carrying that static
effect the Japanese version is
incredible too with them reversing the
footage so it seems more unnatural we
also had that final eyes shot with the
actor behind cutting their eyelashes off
to seem more imposing either way it's
one of the best ways you could end a
movie like this with us finally getting
the scare that they've been teasing
throughout Rachel discovers his body
whereas in the Japanese version when
Reiko arrives she learns that the
characters already been dead for a while
in that he was found by his girlfriend
Maya whereas here Rachel leaves and then
sees his going up in the LIF let's say
just discover him nice but this is just
to stop people asking questions about
the tape the less I know the better as
this will make other people investigate
it just like how she did now as I
mentioned before the Japanese version
has her getting her dad to see the son's
copy whereas here we don't know who
watched it next we see here looking at
the tap of the sofa whereas in the
Japanese version It's pointed out by a
spirit of someone who appears in it now
after Rachel makes sure Aiden presses
the Tye in he says it's going to keep
going as it cutting out of the static we
once more end with brief flashes of it
implying that we the viewers are going
to be the next victim now Rachel herself
has very much become like Samara and
that she doesn't really care about who
she kills next all she cares about is
passing on the virus of the tape Without
Really caring about who it's going to
harm that's very much what samaro was
doing as well and she's just attacking
strangers and ending their lives they
weren't the people who caused the
tragedy to happen to her but in the end
they became a victim of it that's also
what Rachel's doing too with these
unsuspecting people being pulled into it
it's a dark way to close out the film
and we end on a nihilistic final scene
in both versions and that closes out
some of my favorite horrors of all time
with the original ringu still remaining
one of the best I absolutely love the
active characters we have here that go
out searching things instead of sitting
around waiting to get killed this is
such a good film that massively changed
horror and Samara and Sadako both became
icons in their own right aided by
handsome as score this is one of the
most unnerving Horrors from my childhood
and I hope you've had a good time going
back through it also shout outs to the
channel Alexander Palm as the guy put
together a compilation of the side by
side stuff that we then added the
background and logos to but still it's
it's his edit so I wouldn't really just
want to jack it without giving him
Credit Now if you've enjoyed the video
then please hit the thumbs up button and
if you want to see these breakdowns
early then please hit the join button
for just 99 C and 99 a month you'll get
audio versions of these early the edited
ones too and Early Access to our podcast
across the spoiler version and basically
any video we've done in advance that
doesn't break embargo huge thank you to
all the members who've signed up so far
it honestly it really means the world to
me and it just means that videos like
this can get made and we can focus on
talking about the classics now if you
want something else to watch then please
check out our breakdown of Halloween
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over all the creepy details in it
and things you might not know so
definitely head over there right after
this without the way huge thank you for
clicking this I've been Paul and I'll
see you next time you take care don't
listen to that phone ring and make sure
you subscribe otherwise you'll be dead
in 7 days cuz sniper wolle show up to
your house and climb out the TV anyway
thank you for watching this I'll see you
next time bye